welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
mandalorian season 2 episode 3
chapter 11 the heiress an episode that
will make you hate quorns even more but
a spoiler warning for the episode make
you love clone wars even more
for the live-action arrival of bocaton
crees
and someone finally telling denjarin no
dude you're the weird one take off your
damn helmet and stop drinking that
kool-aid
oh and be sure to check out wikileaks if
you haven't already i couldn't be there
this week but tommy and phillips seem to
have it all under control
in this video i'm going to break down
all the interesting easter eggs star
wars references hidden visual details
all the stuff that you might have missed
you know the drill oh and yes i am
wearing our custom this
is the way shirt it is available at
newrockstarsmerch.com if you buy it for
a few bucks more you can write in a
custom shout out in our wikileaks
episodes
what an opportunity all right tomorrow
morning for the episode let's get
started
okay the opening shot of the episode is
the opening shot of the season 2 trailer
the battered razor crest drifting past
the gas giant coal ivan toward the
estuary moon
trask now the orbesh on mando's screen
translates to
stabilizer error and then moments later
landing gear offline
setting up this close call rapid descent
to the trask harbor zone i love how this
descent kind of sets up the key plot
device of the final act of the episode
where those mandalorians use the
imperial freighter needing to clear the
harbor zone first in order to hijack it
before its rapid ascent
an ascent that is reversed to another
rapid descent
into the populated harbor zone after mob
gideon orders it to crash
mando drops some in-universe profanity
dank ferric landing array isn't
responding
yeah that same swear comes up later from
costco reeves
he's one of them thank ferrick and both
are a callback to the moment the mithral
said this in the series pilot episode
that was close and there's some more
great production design details from the
show
as they burn up during the atmosphere
entry condensation drops from the
bulkhead showing how this process is
less of the you know typical clean space
travel we always see in the star wars
universe
and instead more like what the early
nasa apollo missions went through during
their re-entry
and you can also see how this extreme
heat causes the water in the frog ladies
canister to begin to boil
though we don't have to worry she did
soak those things in a hot spring i also
appreciated how that proximity alert on
mando's landing uses the same sound
effect from other ships we've seen in
star wars when they get a lock on the
target
[Music]
but the crazier most insane detail is
the orbesh here this is why i always try
to translate it these letters translate
to
the words of course i still love you
which is an interesting sci-fi reference
to
a name of one of the two sentient ships
and ian embanks the player of games from
the culture novels
the other ship's name was just read the
instructions elon musk also named his
spacex drone ships as a reference to
these as well so i'm thinking here maybe
the mandalorian series crew might have
named the ship contacting mando this as
a similar kind of reference
but uh before i get to that i want to
thank bessie shoes for sponsoring this
breakdown
look there are two things we can all
agree on nobody wants anything bad to
happen to baby yoda ever
and nobody likes wet feet it's just
those two lucky for us bessie makes
these great knit sneakers that are 100
waterproof and weatherproof they are
super
breathable too with an antimicrobial
insole so your feet
smell as good as they look i i i presume
i haven't been looking at your feet
bestie shoes are super stretchy they fit
like a sock they only weigh 175 grams
which is insanely light considering they
are stronger than carrot dune in an arm
wrestling match they're also made with
the space age dynamex material so these
are shoes that you can wear every day no
matter the weather they're also
sustainably made and
super easy to clean whether you're
hurting nerfs farming moisture or just
running around town in winter weather
besties will keep your feet warm and dry
and looking great
oh i wish i could still swim
oh no my shoe got in the pool water but
wait a minute
my toes are so dry thanks to these messy
knit stickers
[Music]
they also have an incredible early black
friday offer going on right now so go
grab yourself a pair for the rainy
season while they still have sizes and
you can thank me later check them out in
the link below and if you miss a black
friday sale
use my code new rockstars to get 25 off
your fessy shoes
now the crane that dredges the razor
crest from the water looks like a
retrofitted atat
or at both are okay so let's leave it at
that
but what i love about this one being
used this way is that lucasfilm's art
team originally designed these
for the empire strikes back by taking
inspiration from the massive port
cranes in oakland so in a way these are
kind of coming full circle with their
original function
on trask are aquatic beings the quarrens
and the mon calamari like our old pal
admiral akbar
it's a trap both are native to the ocean
world mancala aka doc
and they've never really gotten along
they did actually have a civil war
during the clone wars era but anakin
skywalker was able to broker a truce
between them now a little detail in the
pub i love is how corns
season their food after pelimoto
preferring her meat medium rare it's
just fun to see another example of
culinary preferences
these kind of choices have been what
john favreau was referring to
when dave filoni said things like a dime
a dozen don't exist in the star wars
universe
and mando pays the pub owner with some
squishy flan currency
which we also saw back in the first
episode of the series and then uh from
baby otis chowder a squid
latches onto his face xenomorph
facehugger style another example of the
alien motif we saw a lot of last episode
now the quorum boat that they take out
looks like a retrofitted hammerhead
class corvette the one another famous
mon calamari admiral raddus used to
knock disabled imperial star destroyers
into each other during the battle of
scarif in rogue one
but those dirty trickster quarrens trap
mando by feeding baby ota to a mamacore
this
i think is a new beast in the star wars
universe but it's interesting to note
that mando's jetpack seems to work
underwater apparently
but manto gets saved by dank ferrick
boca tan crees
played by katie sackov and axe wolves
played by simon cassian 80s from agents
of shield and
costco reeves wwe star sasha banks now
boca tan is a hugely important character
in the star wars animated series clone
wars and rebels she was once a member of
the death watch but she
left that group after maul took over the
group and then used them to steal the
mandalorian throne poketan's sister is
duchess sateen
former ruler of mandalore and one-time
love interest to
obi-wan kenobi hello there
chronologically we last saw bocatan
in star wars rebels she was wielding the
ancient
mandalorian sword of the dark saber and
using it to
unite the mandalorian people but most
recently in our time we saw her in clone
wars season seven right after ahsoka
helped her retake mandalore but right as
order 66 was about to go
out it is so cool to see these night
owls fight ludwig joran's sith
percussion is so intense and
the three of them move so fluidly in
sync just as bo katan's animated version
from clone wars does but what i like
about it is it's an interesting contrast
to the way mando fights
he has a more defensive oh just let
anyone hit me approach
because he is a loner and he is learning
how to be part of a tribe now boca dan's
helmet and armor are painted with these
owl markings just like they are in the
animated series you can also see it on
their shoulder patches these are for the
night owl group this is a group she
formed after leaving the death watch
and you are a child of the watch yeah
poketan is reminding us that mando was
actually saved by
that previous group of hers the watch
thus their three-pronged scratchy sigil
that we saw in that flashback and
poketan gives us some much
needed clarity about why mando was so
strict about never removing his helmet
yes not all mandalorians are this strict
but it's just his
group he's a kind of cult of zealots
that broke away from the mandalorian
society to rebuild
after the purge using strict ancient
traditions to do so
and when they free baby oda from the
mamacore his carrier is dented i've
always found it interesting that that
carrier is designed
to look like an egg a bit of ironic
justice for that little fatso eating all
the eggs last episode
now his egg gets swallowed now later
bokutan declares her objective
we're seizing those weapons and using
them to retake our home world
once we've done that we'll seat any
mandalore on the throne
that planet is cursed anyone who goes
there dies
once the empire knew they couldn't
control it they made sure no one else
could either
don't believe everything you hear
interesting so apparently the empire has
been using propaganda to try to scare
mandalorians from trying to return to
their home world
which does connect with how moth gideon
used that war crime tragedy term the
night of a thousand tears but as a
leader of the mandalorian resistance
bogatan
obviously sees that defeat as totally
reversible now they plot to hijack this
imperial gozanshi freighter
a ship that we have seen in the animated
series and briefly in the background of
most espa when qui-gon and the others
arrived in phantom menace mando leaves
baby yoda with the adorable frog couple
whose eggs now begin to hatch into
tadpoles meaning they have been
fertilized from the night before nice on
the imperial freighter the siren is the
same
that we've heard on imperial craters
since empire love that they brought that
back and it is captained by this
imperial commander based on his insignia
played by
titus welver aka the man in black from
lost love this guy
and if you look closely on the bridge
display the orbis translates to
breach i do love how these stormtroopers
report that there are 10 pirates maybe
more
when yeah the pilot just reads that the
thermal scans verify there are only
four of them idiots comedy actor kevin
dorf cameos is the imperial officer who
locks them in the cargo
control area allowing the mandalorians
to blow them out the cargo door now boca
tan says to the bridge
put some tea on we'll be up in a minute
this is some example of some consistent
universe details like in clone wars tea
is a big thing to the people in
mandalore like pre-vizsla drinks with
maul and pre-vizilla was voiced by john
fabro
time for tea come join me poketan was
with the death watch at the time and
dave palone produced all this so all
this episode is like a big reunion
that's why we fans are really loving it
now poketan aims specifically to get the
dark saber back this is of course the
sacred mandalorian sword that dates way
back to ancient times
this tells us that moth gideon must have
taken the saber during the purge but the
fact that she wasn't certain that he
took it suggests that
she didn't lose the saber in a duel with
him face to face but that maybe he like
snatched it away while she was elsewhere
during that fight but mob gideon orders
the officer to crash the freighter
saying
long live the apartment interesting so
it sounds like this imperial
group are as insanely committed zealots
to their lost cause of the empire as
mando's tribe is to his way now we know
after the empire collapsed that
palpatine issued what was called
operation
cinder a scorched earth plan to take
down a ton of planets in the galaxy
along with the empire that could have
been part of what gideon did with the
purge of mandalore but this group seems
to be more forward-looking they got some
plans they want the child they're doing
something could be clone related could
be connected with the empire secret plot
to resurrect palpatine
and rebuild the sith fleet that we see a
generation later in the rise of
skywalker
so i gotta say i hope not i kind of want
to forget that happened but actor titus
well over so great when he gets that
suicide order notice what he does he
takes his subtle subtle gulp as if he is
sucking out his suicide
pill in that moment and then later when
he bites down on it it fries his jaw
with electricity
an interesting visual parallel with the
way the emperor sith lightning
sizzled hater's teeth when he threw him
over the ledge and ahsoka finally
reveals to us tomato can find ahsoka
tano
who's probably gonna appear next episode
played by rosario dawson and i love how
i don't think we have seen any of that
footage in any promo footage or trailer
she apparently is on the forest planet
corvus
in the city of kaladan which as far as i
can tell are new
locations in the star wars universe and
then mando leaves bogotan by echoing her
this is a way telling it back to her a
sign that this guy
might have finally moved a bit in his
stubbornness and his dogma
closer toward a place of religious
tolerance and i love how that final
image leaves a tiny tiny little piece of
that poorly repaired razor crest behind
almost as if to say
mando's character shell is starting to
wither away to reveal the beautiful
human soul
underneath that is all i noticed in the
episode again you can help support this
channel and get yourself some great
apparel and accessories at
newrockstarsmerch.com check it out
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification button follow me at ea boss
follow me rockstar see you next time i
have spoken
[Music]
you